these are volatile times dangerous times
war has already broken out in eastern
europe if the crisis is not handled with
prudence and resolve and restraint and
foresight the conflict could well spread
across the globe
sending us barreling headfirst into
another world war
this is a time for competent assured
intelligent leadership it's unfortunate
then that the western world is led by
the most pathetic collection of morally
bankrupt half-wits our civilization has
ever seen
these are the people we must entrust to
to guide us through this calamity
without getting 50 million people killed
in the process frankly i don't love the
odds right now
and i'm not feeling any better today
considering what happened in dc last
night
with the world teetering on the brink of
nuclear destruction congress which could
never be accused of having its
priorities straight
got together to work on making lynching
illegal
yes that violent act which literally
hasn't occurred one single time in this
country in at least 40 years
that's the thing they decided to focus
on
they might as well pass a law
prohibiting the use of giant catapults
to storm fortresses
maybe next they can finally legally ban
people from burning witches at the stake
how about a law once again um abolishing
the transatlantic slave trade
now i'm not being totally fair they
didn't just work on outlawing lynching
they also tried to um do some other
things like they they tried to pass a
bill
banning something called hair
discrimination
that's hair discrimination
it's called the creating a respectful
and open world for natural hair or crown
act
and it would make it illegal to
discriminate against hairstyles worn by
black people now you might be thinking
that
discrimination against black people is
already illegal and it is
but this bill would make a black
person's hairstyle its own protected
class
so black people would be protected from
discrimination twice over once for their
whole body and then a second time for
the top of their heads
eventually i'm sure democrats will pass
laws specifically protecting each
marginalized body part individually so
we've covered head discrimination what
about shoulder discrimination what about
knees and toes and eyes and ears and
mouth and nose head shoulders knees and
toes knees and toes
you can tell i have a two-year-old at
home sorry about that but the dreadlock
protection act of 2022 uh didn't pass uh
that was one bit of empty virtue
signaling that republicans refused to go
along with the same cannot be said for
the anti-lynching act however
which was an even more dangerous and
grotesque form of virtue signaling but
as for that republicans were fully on
board
save for three there were three
republicans who rightfully voted against
the measure including thomas massey
from kentucky who's you know one of the
only good ones left
but they were not enough to prevent this
bill from passing and so the the emmett
till anti-lynching act was passed with
near near unanimous support from both
parties and the bill now makes it a
federal hate crime
to lynch somebody or to conspire to
lynch somebody
now before the bill's passage various
members of congress took turns you know
standing on the floor of congress
bravely denouncing this despicable act
which was already illegal
and which doesn't happen anymore at all
to anybody
squad member cory bush of course made
sure to get her time in the spotlight
listen to her
those
who survived the middle passage survived
only to be brought onto these shores
bought and sold at auctions like the
goods their forced labor was producing
these auctions launched a long-standing
practice in america
in which white folks including white
women
scrutinize and violate the bodies of
black people especially black women
we're going to tell the truth today
black adults and black children enslaved
and forced to endure being tormented
being tortured being raped by white
slave owners on owners on slave ships
and on the plantations
our ancestors
tried to escape the bondage of slavery
just to be hunted
captured imprisoned
executed
executed
why is she uh talking about this why is
she talking about slavery and why does
she pretend that in denouncing slavery
she's bravely telling a truth that
nobody else will say out loud
we're going to tell the truth today
oh how brave about slavery
i was joking before about the democrats
outlawing slavery all over again maybe
that's really where this is headed
and i guess i can see why the democrats
were all in favor of slavery the first
time around so it's only fair to give
them a chance to you know get on the
right side of the issue but as for the
anti-lynching act
two points must be emphasized
one as discussed
nobody is getting lynched in modern
america thank god
the last case was in 1981
five years before i was born
and that was an extraordinary event
because it was the first such occurrence
in decades
so since my parents were born you could
count the number of lynchings on maybe
like one hand and you may not need all
your fingers
since i was born it hasn't happened at
all
not once
anywhere in the country
now does that mean that it should be
legal well of course not
and the good news is that it's not legal
it's always been illegal
if you lynch a person today with or
without this bill
you will go to prison for a very long
time
though ironically with this bill you may
actually go to prison for a shorter
length of time than you otherwise would
have
because the legislation prescribes a
sentence of not more than 30 years now i
would have thought that lynching should
carry a life sentence or a death
sentence but you know that's just me
i guess i'm tougher on lynching than um
than the democrats are does it make
sense that the same company who controls
half of online retail also passively
eavesdrops on your private conversations
at home what about the idea that a
single company controls 90 of internet
searches runs your email service and
gets to track everything you do on your
smartphone big tech is more powerful
than most countries are and they profit
by exploiting your personal data it's
time to put a layer of protection
between your online activity and these
tech giants and that's why i use
expressvpn think about how much of your
life is on the internet sadly every site
you visit video you watch message you
send gets tracked and data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you so expressvpn makes your
activity harder to trace and also harder
to sell to advertisers expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your internet data to
keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers on your network as well so
stop handing over your personal data to
the big tech monopoly who minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself with the vpn i trust to
keep me safe visit expressvpn.com
matt walsh show to get three extra
months free in fact lynching isn't just
already illegal
race-based lynching
lynchings committed for racist reasons
are illegal twice over
okay because lynching is murder or
attempted murder which is illegal if
it's racially motivated then it's
race-based violence which is already a
hate crime
so no black people are getting lynched
in america but if such a horrific event
did occur
it would already be illegal twice
illegal on the state and the federal
level
illegal and then illegal again
so this law makes it illegal a third
time
why stop there let's make it illegal
four times
let's make it illegal every year by 2030
that we should have over 10 laws
outlawing a crime that nobody is
committing anyway
by the way this is true even if you
expand the definition of lynching to
include things that are not lynching
which is what the left has done in order
to make the case that lynching is still
a problem in the united states what
they'll always do is they'll say well
george floyd was a lynching victim
or a mod arbory
but words have meanings
and those don't apply
if if lynching now just means any
violence committed against a black man
by a white man for allegedly racist
reasons well again
that's already illegal
the wikipedia article lynching in the
united states actually lists a mod
arbory as a victim if you go to
wikipedia and you trust them as a source
they have a list of all the victims of
lynching and they have
according to them there's been one case
of lynching
in uh in the 21st century and a mod
arbory was the victim
except that he was not lynched and
anyway
his killers have already been convicted
of murder and a hate crime
so even under the expanded definition of
lynching
in fact especially under the expanded
definition there's no need for this law
it already exists
so what is the point
i mean why are they doing this
well the primary point obviously is to
virtue signal
treating the law itself like at some
kind of twitter hashtag
now all of these lawmakers can appear in
campaign videos declaring that they
bravely took a stand and finally once
and for all banned this terrible
practice
they'll just hope that their
constituents are too stupid to realize
that it was already banned and also that
they were wasting time on this empty
stunt
while the world stood at the precipice
of nuclear annihilation but there's
something else too
and this is what makes this uh more than
an empty stunt and more than just a
silly and pointless symbolic gesture but
something far more sinister as well this
is also why spineless republicans should
have refused to go along with the
charade but they didn't refuse because
they're well spineless
and that is this the law is meant to
send a message
that lynching is still a current and
urgent problem in the united states
that's that's that's what this is it's
psychological conditioning
it's kind of like you know if you stand
in a crowd and you look up at the sky
inquisitively everybody else will look
up to they'll assume that because you're
looking up there there must be something
there
and so when congress passes a law
banning lynching for the third time
stupid people will assume that okay well
if they had to pass a law banning
lynching then i guess it still happens
so this is all part of the overarching
effort to paint our country as
systemically racist against minorities
which it is not
it is a narrative booster most of all
and that's what our leaders are
concerned with at a time like this
because they're not leaders
we have no leaders in this country
only parasites and con artists playing
the part
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated